the ending of moon knight does some
heavy lifting to wrap up the season's
story and then at the last minute it
seriously pulls the rug out from under
the viewer's feet warning spoilers for
moon night episode six ahead
mark specter
stephen and grant
whoever else might be in there
as arthur harrow notes in moon knight
the head of mark spector stephen grant
is more than a little crowded by the
time the finale episode is over this
umpteenth little tease about another
personality's existence comes into play
in a major way despite the warnings of
taw eric mark spector turns back to his
peaceful field of reads and chooses to
rescue stephen from duot he still finds
a form of peace though after finally
confessing that he needs steven to keep
together and even calling the cheerful
brit identity his only true superpower a
pretty heavy statement from a guy who
wields powers granted by a moon god
with that mark and steven become whole
return to their body and become moon
knight and mr knight again unfortunately
even their combined forces aren't quite
enough to defeat hero who comes within
inches of killing mark however after
mark experiences another unexplained
mid-fight blackout it's hero who lies
helpless on the ground
at this point even the most casual
viewer probably suspects that a third
unseen identity is responsible for
knocking harrow's glass-filled shoes off
his feet after all the show has teased
this dangerous persona's existence since
episode three
stephen what did you do i swear it
wasn't me then who was it
by the time the post-credits scene comes
along the jake lockley identity indeed
makes his presence known wearing his
signature flat cap the violent jake
hijacks hero from the hospital and
shoots him while konshu looks on in this
short scene this new persona establishes
himself as a ruthless and capable
operator what's worse he's still
willingly working with konshu and since
he occupies the same body as stephen and
mark it appears that none of them are as
free from the lunar god's servitude as
they think moon knight has been teasing
the possibility that leila el puli might
become the new avatar of konchu for a
while and while she does gain
avatar-based superpowers in episode 6
this happens in a very different way
than you might think sure the show
teases a leila as moon knight moment
when she releases kanchu from his mini
statue prison and the moon god offers to
make her his new avatar leila promptly
refuses and even attempts to browbeat
konchu into partnership instead of a
servitude deal this doesn't go
particularly well but as it turns out
this isn't the first time layla cold
shoulders and egyptian gods avatar
offered that day
only an avatar can do it
i said
no
earlier in the episode tara delivers
mark's message to layla and throws in a
far less ominous avatar deal in the
process wary of mark's negative
experiences layla initially turns
tarrara down but reconsiders upon
learning that team egyptian pantheon
needs more avatars to successfully trap
amit as such she accepts the hippo
goddess's offer this proves to be a good
call because the delighted to eric
provides layla with some welcome
information about her father's afterlife
situation and grants her a cool winged
costume
wow you look amazing what are you
wearing
layla appears to highly enjoy her new
avatar powers what's more the show
pretty much states that she's not going
anywhere anytime soon when a young girl
asks whether she's an egyptian superhero
and layla immediately confirms that she
is just like that moon knight has
delivered the origin story of a
character who's been confirmed to be the
scarlet scarab making her debut in the
mcu
harrow continues his penance-filled path
in this episode of moon knight and his
mission to let amit clean the world
keeps adding to the show's body count
after pulling assorted don't resist and
you don't get hurt stunts including one
on the egyptian gods avatars he finally
releases the crocodile-headed judgment
deity who probably makes hero her
official avatar from this point on
things play out very much like harold
promised in episode 1. emmett's
followers start cleansing the world and
the goddess feasts on the souls of
scales deem unworthy unfortunately for
the villains the plan is rudely
interrupted by the freshly resurrected
moon knight and the taoiret powered
layla who managed to defeat hero and
trap amit in his body the shock is
enough to hospitalize hero but even then
he finds no peace despite amit's
promises instead jake lockley
unceremoniously abducts and shoots him
destroying amits in the process
it's not exactly a surprise that the
villain loses in the end but the way
episode vi presents harrow as a
vulnerable hurt and deeply regretful man
who's simply going through his twisted
perception of doing the right thing is a
pretty nice take for an mcu antagonist
by the time he's forced to act as amit's
living broken vessel hero has clearly
endured so much pain that even the
hitherto implacable dr harrell construct
in mark's mind is hurt and terrified
few mcu properties can escape the big
cgi ending battle so by the time harrow
stands on the pyramid and moon knight is
flying around it's clear that moon
knight is about to deliver on this front
instead of the harrow moon knight
showdown that you might have been
expecting though the show turns his
ultimate battle into a full-on super
team fight moon knight keeps alternating
between his main costume and steven's mr
knight persona the freshly advertised
leila soon turns up to help and harold's
cultist keeps stirring the pot in the
background ammit and konchu keep
themselves busy with a kaiju sized
grudge match this goes pretty much as
you'd expect after almost getting
defeated the good guys ultimately win
the night and even steven gets to
demonstrate some sweet moves however
this being moon night the real battle is
just beginning and ultimately inside
mark's head as the post-credits scene
reveals kanju is taken to deploying
mark's third personality jake as his
secret avatar which effectively renders
his release of mark and steven
completely moot as they share the same
body
and so like cycles of the moon the
protagonist ends where he began in
steven's messy london apartment when the
confused main character's leg chained to
his bed and a futile attempt to stop
blackout walking and the same song
playing in the background meanwhile a
mysterious violent personality is making
moves out in the world
moon knight doesn't shy away from the
fact that konchu isn't the nicest or
most effective deity around as everyone
from harrow to layla is quick to point
out he's an abusive and treacherous
entity at the best of times and kanchu
himself is quick to confirm all the
negative reviews with his condescending
attitude overly theatrical delivery and
rampant name calling it doesn't exactly
help the moon god's case that he manages
to get himself trapped in a statue
halfway through the show and starts
throwing shade at layla the second she
releases him the end of moon knight
episode 6 however features copious consu
action and makes it clear that the deity
is far more than a pompous poser not
only does he fearlessly engage the
dangerous ammet in combat on two
separate occasions but he also reveals
himself as a kind of ruthless trickster
that loki would be proud of his interest
in laila as a potential future avatar
was a faint all along and the moon god
has actually been working with mark's
jake lockley identity to ensure that he
stays in conscious service though kanchu
is technically fighting evil it
certainly seems that he's no angel
himself and may actually be outright
dangerous he's extremely dedicated to
keeping mark steven jake as his avatar
and his final scene in the episode hints
at this obsession is about to turn
hostile not only does he outright
declare that mark's troubles have only
just begun but his new sweet suit
resembles the outfit he wears in the
jeff lemire pen moon knight comics where
konchu is the villain
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]